now to Ukraine and new concerns about
the safety of the largest nuclear
facility in Europe over the weekend at
least a dozen explosions were heard
around the dapparisha nuclear power
plant which has been in Russia's hands
since February Chris livesay is in the
city of zaparisa which has been
repeatedly bombarded by the Russian
military Chris good morning to you
good morning Gail it was one of the most
serious instances at the plant in recent
months that's according to the iaea the
U.N nuclear Watchdog of a Russian forces
continue to hold the plant hostage along
with all of the workers there yet we
managed to speak to one of the workers
inside
more than a dozen shells slammed into
this building over the weekend
sad reality made terrifying by the
Target the zapariza nuclear power plant
shelled repeatedly since March
[Applause]
the world has held its breath since
Russian forces seized it at the start of
the war its six reactors caught in the
crossfire now at Great personal risk one
of the workers held hostage inside is
providing regular updates to our team in
a CBS News exclusive do you think
there's any risk of a nuclear meltdown
Russian forces are capable of anything
they behave like monkeys playing with
hand grenades they're Reckless and
stupid as for why sabotage Moscow has
already tried and failed to steal the
plant by linking it to the Russian grid
now it wants to make sure Ukraine can
never use it again he says of course
this is incredibly dangerous as Mariano
Grossi the director of un's nuclear
Watchdog told cbs's 60 minutes until we
have this plant protected the
possibility of a nuclear catastrophe is
there a catastrophe the worker tells us
Russian forces could attempt to wield as
a weapon do you have any reason to fear
that Russia has plans to turn this
nuclear power plant into a nuclear bomb
personally I don't have any evidence of
dirty bomb but I'm not allowed to walk
freely through the plant they're
certainly preparing something but what
exactly I don't know
now to be clear what he suspects Russian
forces are trying to do is dismantle the
nuclear plant so Russia so Ukrainian
forces can never use it again it's an
extremely risky Gambit meanwhile the
iaea has been granted access inside and
so far they say there are no clear signs
of a security or safety risk Nate
Chris let's say in Ukraine thank you